Okay. Bernie, I haven't reached the end of my initial contracts yet for my first clients.
Any tips to get the renewal? Yes. Super simple. I like to bump things up. I like to give them a
lot of soft touches leading up six weeks, a month up. Sometimes I'll bump the ads up a little bit
just to make sure they have a really good month. And then we have the conversation. And I make sure
to have the conversation about four weeks to two weeks out so that if they don't want to renew,
I have time to go find somebody else. But yeah, make sure that that last two weeks,
four weeks before you have the chat is a good one. Okay. And not only that you send them a
lot of leads, but that they're actually closing deals. You got to make sure to stay in touch with
these people. Make sure to have a lot of soft touches during that first six months. And then
once you re-sign into that year, dude, it becomes a lot easier. And that's the beauty is there is
light at the end of the tunnel.